This video is brought to you by skill
share.
Okay.
What's up guys?
Jared again.
Today we're talking about the Walt
Disney of animate hi Yao Miyazaki with
11 feature films and over 125 major
awards under his belt.
Miyazaki's become a household name even
in the West.
So what gives the films of me as Aki and
his team of bad asses at Studio Ghibli
that extra Miyuzaki feel well beneath
all the curse tentacle pigs and giant
cat bear things.
There's a cohesive philosophy at play
here.
The Japanese religion of Shinto welcome,
this wisecrack condition on the
philosophy of Miyazaki and you know the
drill spoilers ahead.
A recurrent theme throughout all of me
as archies films is a love for nature.
At times.
This can be fairly over the top,
such as in the battle between the humans
and the forest and princess monotone.
Okay.
What I want is for the humans and the
forest to live in peace or the battle
between the various armies and bugs and
Nasca of the Valley of the wind.
Humans cannot live.
Actually let's roll the opening credits
for Nasca for a second.
Yup.
There it is.
The throne even comes with the World
Wildlife Fund stamp of approval.
While we could chalk all these moments
up to me as Aki being a tree hugger,
seriously,
he's actually opening a nature sanctuary
later this year.
We think it has more to do with Shinto,
which holds a deep respect for nature.
For the uninitiated,
Shinto is an ancient Japanese religion
that believes we share our world with a
variety of gods and spirits called Kami.
Importantly,
comey is both singular and plural,
referring not only to the myriad of
spirits in the world,
but also the divine essence that
connects all things.
This interconnectedness is critical to
understanding the religion,
whereas you and I might see a giant tree
and think,
wow,
that's a big country.
A shintoist might recognize it as a your
machito or an object in which a god can
reside.
It's no longer just nature,
but part of the divine fabric of reality
and as such deserves our respect.
And while Japan is one of the least
religious countries in the world,
over 80% of its population participates
in Shinto traditions.
Seriously.
The only thing Japan has more of than
shrines are vending machines.
But how does this all relate to nature
and Miyazaki?
Well,
according to historian Lynn white
religion plays a large part in shaping a
culture is treatment of the environment.
For example,
Judeo Christian tradition state that man
has dominion over fish of the sea and
over fowl of the air and over every
living thing that moveth upon the earth.
Basically in the west nature has
historically been our bitch.
But in Shinto,
because everything possesses a spiritual
component,
the religion is non anthropocentric.
Humans aren't at the center of the
universe.
And for our boy Miyazaki,
that means that his films deal a lot
with peace and loving between human in
nature.
So if you're wondering why the
protagonist from NASA,
the Valley of the wind,
continually to make peace with some
pretty terrifying bugs.
Well there you go.
Please forgive us for disturbing your
nest.
We're very sorry.
We are not your enemies.
We mean you no harm.
Consider my neighbor Totoro when sisters
Sawicki and May Coosa Kabe moved to an
idealic village out in the country,
they find themselves living alongside a
whole host of spirits in their attic.
For example,
running around the go,
hey,
or a charm that blesses a house is a
swarm of little suit sprites.
But instead of portraying these adorable
little guys as other worldly,
the local wise woman treats them like
familiar wildlife or a kind of ghost,
then don't worry dear then nothing to be
afraid to have.
If they decide you're nice people,
they won't harm you.
And after a I live,
just go wait.
In this world,
spirits aren't something to fear but
rather a part of everyday life.
This casual acceptance of spirits place
in the world and the respect they
deserve is captured in small moments
throughout the film.
Like when sought ski gives thanks to a
local shrine for offering her shelter
from the rain or when the Coosa Kabe
family pays respects to the your Shiro
in which the god of the forest Todaro
lives.
Thank you for watching over May and
making us feel so welcome here.
Please continue to look after us and
it's through befriending these spirits,
particularly the large totaro that our
heroes resolve the films.
Big crisis when may goes missing at the
end,
it's towed.
Rowe who helps sought ski find her with
the help of this weird cat bus thing.
I seriously,
I don't know what to call that.
By having his protagonist respect both
the spirit and the wildlife they
inhabit.
Miyuzaki inverts traditional Western
views toward the environment in the
west.
We've historically looked at the land in
terms of its instrumental value,
what it can do for us.
For example,
aristotle remarked in his book,
politics.
Nature has made all things specifically
for the sake of man and for us red,
white and blue blooded Americans.
We can see this in the concept of
manifest destiny II,
how we must spread out across the
country and convert all this nature into
usable land.
In short,
we're consumers and the earth is our
Walmart.
However,
if we factor in that the land is imbued
with spirits,
then we have to concede that the earth
might have some intrinsic value,
I.
E.
Value for its own sake,
much like haunt formulated that people
or more broadly rational agents must be
treated as an end,
never merely as a means.
So too must the land which is full of
thinking,
rational spirits be treated as an end,
not as a means.
And it's in how these two perspectives
on nature fail to meet that we find the
root of conflict in me as archies films.
For example,
look at Ponyo Miyazaki's take on the
little mermaid in it.
The Magician Fujimoto opposes his
daughter Ponyo his desire to become a
human on the grounds that they use the
ocean for their own gain.
In fact,
the only why Ponyo ends up meeting the
little boys so ski in the first place is
because she gets swept up by a passing
ship,
trawling the ocean,
or in layman's terms,
when a ship essentially rakes the ocean
with a giant net destroying reefs and
underwater habitats all for a quick
buck.
When Fujimoto finally recovers Ponyo he
offers some pretty scathing criticism of
mankind.
What do you know about humans?
The score in the sea.
They treat your home like the empty
black songs.
That was one slung.
I go,
what she wanted myself.
I had to leave that all behind to serve
the earth.
That's right.
Apparently you can't love the ocean and
be human at the same time.
And to be fair,
this clash between intrinsic and
instrumental value has some pretty dire
consequences because ponos father
refuses to let his daughter become a
human.
And because Ponyo refuses to go back to
being a fish,
the natural order of the world begins to
fall apart.
The moon falls closer to the sea.
The waves take on a life of their own,
and half the town looks like a coloring
book page inspired by the day after
tomorrow.
But so ca ponyo manage to stave off the
end of days by proving that humans can
love nature for itself in the most
literal way possible.
After helping so skate traverse the
flooded island to get back to his mom,
Ponyo uses up all her magical power and
returns to being a fish when asked by
pose mother,
the spirit of the earth and goddess of
mercy herself.
If so,
ski knew that Ponyo was a fish and could
love her.
Anyway.
He responds,
I love
so demonstrates that humans can
intrinsically value nature by actually
falling in love with the fish.
Relieved Ponyo his mother puts her
daughter in a bubble and with a kiss
from so skate Ponyo transforms
permanently into a real girl,
thereby putting the world at ease again,
while Ponyo chooses to ground this
mismatch of values and a Romeo and
Juliet sorta way more often than not in
Miyazaki films,
we see it embodied in the conflict
between nature and technology and
perhaps nowhere is this interplay more
noticeable than in me is Aki is darkest
work.
Princess modern.
Okay.
In the film prints,
Asha Taka travel to the industrial
holdout irontown to understand what's
causing the great spirits of the forest
to become cursed.
As it turns out,
irontown under the leadership of Lady of
OCI has been cutting down the forest in
order to bolster its own supply of iron
in choosing their own material gain over
the sanctity of the forest.
The residents of irontown have started
an all out war with the god of the
mountain,
a war which Asha Taka is determined to
stop.
What's particularly interesting is how
the townspeople viewed this,
these four station in relation to the
idea of progress before lady of Bocce
came along,
they tell Asha Taka that it was
impossible to settle here.
The problem was before we could dig for
the iron,
we had to clear away the forest and
that's what made the board angry.
Hello?
Then one day the lady bull,
she came along with their warriors in
the right.
Awesome.
This last point is important.
The town's people view iron and guns and
more broadly rationality as a vehicle
for progress with science and
rationality on their side.
Humans think they can live anywhere and
to anything,
but it's exactly this mindset that
philosophy's Ron Swanson.
Martin Heidegger says leads to a warped
idea of reality because we're focused on
viewing nature only through the lens of
science and technology.
We're blinded to the true essence of
things.
So trees become,
would beaches become iron sand and a
giant walking God becomes a big pain in
the ass.
Nothing is sacred anymore.
And this is especially true to lady of
Boshi.
She's not even afraid of that God,
that woman.
And while the forward march of
technology has brought some good to the
townspeople,
empowering women and giving work to the
literal lepers of society,
it also comes with some pretty big
drawbacks.
Namely angry wolves,
bores monkeys,
and some pretty nasty curses.
So what's the overall takeaway here are
all of me is Auggie's films just thinly
veiled odes to nature.
And it's the message really as simple as
trees are good in technology is bad.
Well,
let's not go full thorough just yet.
After all,
nature can be pretty damn scary.
And me as Aki films in the futuristic
apocalyptic nightmare that is NASA,
the Valley of the wind,
the humans live in a world invaded by a
toxic jungle,
told to believe these spores can kill me
without a mask.
Oh yeah.
And did we mention these swarms of
massive killer insects that live in it?
Similarly,
spirits aren't always your friend in
Miyazaki's most famous work spirited
away.
The little girl Chihiro enters a
mysterious deserted town with her
parents only for them to be turned into
pigs and you hero's quest to change her
parents back.
Chanters a service of an evil witch you
Baba and runs into this unruly patron,
no face.
Yep.
Not exactly a friendly figure like
Totoro,
but if nature and spirits aren't always
good,
then it stands to reason that society
and technology aren't always bad.
Case and point in the wind rises
Miyazaki's last film technology is never
presented as something to fear.
In fact,
it's freak events of nature like a
massive earthquake and disease that
creates a lot of the conflict in this
world.
As the protagonist juro learns in one of
his many dream sequences,
airplanes for him aren't the same as
lady [inaudible] guns.
They're not meant to do battle or to
further materialistic gains as his idol.
Giovanni caproni states airplanes are
not tools for,
they are not for making money and plains
are beautiful.
To me,
engineer's turn dreams into reality.
In the end,
what it all seems to come down to is the
idea of respect and balance.
In Shinto certain actions create a sense
of ritual purity.
They give peace of mind to your own
spirit and those around you,
the dead must be for their souls to be
at peace.
Local gods and wildlife must be shown
respect and their sacrifices even for
the benefit of mankind must be honored.
If not these angered spirits can become
cursed or you know this.
It's not a matter of land being good or
technology being bad so much as it is
about living in harmony with the natural
world to hammer this point home.
Let's have a quick look at castle in the
sky,
which follows the young boy Pazo and the
princess sheet does quest to find the
long lost flying city of La Pito.
As it turns out,
she does ambulate points the way to the
city and with the help of some friendly
air pirates,
the duo racist to reach Lapino before
the military,
but when the pair of finally arrived,
the city's not what they expect in the
century.
Since it's abandonment lop,
UTA has become overgrown with plants and
those scary robots in the distance while
turns out they're more of the big
friendly giant variety.
Instead of killing people,
they tend to the wildlife and much like
in the Shinto tradition,
they also pay their respects to the
debt.
You've picked another flower for the
grave.
How kind of you?
In essence lobby that has become the
perfect synthesis of nature and
technology,
a giant tree even growing around its
main crystal and power source.
It's only when the army arrived and
particularly Mooska that this status is
broken as Mooska violently ripped
through the vegetation that has taken
over Lapi does control room.
He attempts to turn the city into a
massive weapon watching goose because
disregard for the natural world.
She to finally realizes why her people
left die in the first place.
Now I understand why the people of
Laputa vanished.
There was a song from my home in the
valley have gone to with it explains
everything it says,
take root in the ground,
live in harmony with the wind.
Plant your seeds in the winter and
rejoice with the birds.
And the coming of spring,
no matter how many weapons you have,
no matter how great your technology
might be,
the world cannot live without love,
determined to stop Mooska Pausey when
she needs it,
then recite the forbidden spell instead
of letting Musco break the balance of
the world,
they destroy lapita all together.
As the city crumbles though the tree and
the power source remain intact.
Soaring through the sky together.
So what do you think wise crack.
Should we value wildlife for its own
sake,
spirits or not?
Or should we value it for what it can
offer us?
Maybe if not materially,
at least in quality of life or is it
about a balance in all things regardless
of the answer.
A great way to nurture a connection to
nature is by setting up a tiny garden at
home and with skill share.
The online learning community,
you can find classes on how to do just
that along with classes on how to start
a business.
Design an adobe illustrator or code
pixel art for games with over 20,000
classes,
let that sink in.
You could quite possibly take a class a
day for the rest of your life.
So to kickoff the rest of your life
skill shares,
offering the first 500 wise crack fans
to click the link in the description,
two months of skill share for free.
So to sign up,
go to s k l.
Dot.
S h.
Slash wise cracks seven or click the
link in the description below.
Let us know what you thought about me as
Aki in the comments.
And until next time he's,
yeah.